be healthy god be with healthy people
right I'm hanging out with Jim and I got
what is this we're doing our wheat
freshly made wheatgrass juice so you
want to be healthy get with healthy
people and what's the benefits of wheat
wheat grass wheat grass grass grass it's
still growing
it's still alive it's especially rich in
enzyme activity life force energy and
you juice the wheatgrass that's it
you're getting a concentrated amount of
nutrients especially chlorophyll which
is cleansing and healing for the body
and it you know before we knew better
when we were when we were young punks
you know we used to sometimes have go
out to drinking you know have a shot in
the beer well this is this is a
different combination of a shadowy
crafts chase down with a freshly made
organic vegetable juice no that's
support of a upheld penile vitality of
life no alcohol no shots and a bad stuff
but shots are the good stuff this is
wheat grass you can sue grass it's
growing wheat grass juice it's not the
kind of grass that grows in your back
long I know you will you know you
wouldn't you wouldn't want to use a lawn
mower on this strip No
being health conscious being around
healthy people and taking care of let's
leave them with the nutritional
integrity how important that is Oh
nutritional integrity is all about
setting standards for what is acceptable
food and drink for your body and then
being joyfully faithful to those
standards in support of your god-given
ability to be healthy so I'm gonna do my
wheat grass Pune
and re-educating your taste buds because
you can be tricked into liking things
are not good for you
people get tricked into liking things
that are it's reeducate of your taste
buds cleaning your palate and and
learning to enjoy the most nourishing
foods and and drinks that God nature
have to offer us by the point I wanted
to make is people end up they end up
liking things that are bad for them
because and they trick now they feel
like okay it tastes good so it must be
good but no now they try something like
this and they're like oh that's awful
but the point is to re-educate it so
you'd like what's actually good for you
you want to you want to consider having
a whole body experience with what you're
consuming you know it's it's a mistake
to eat as if your taste buds are the
most important part of your body you
know when someone has some type of junk
beverage you know like some type of soft
drink the taste buds maybe having a good
time but your pancreas and your liver
and your endocrine system your immune
system they're not having a good time
they're not enjoying any of that because
consume a soft drink loaded with sugar
and and all kind of chemical additives
you you stressed your body you didn't
nourish yourself but with this even
though initially if this is new to you
your taste buds not might not have such
a good time the rest of your body is
going to be enjoying it very very
profoundly because this is wonderful
nutrition for the immune system and the
endocrine system and the liver and all
of the cells of your body
Peggy Jim
[Music]